hey Vsauce Michael here eating your own
boogers is gross but it might be smart
assuming you have clean fingers lung
specialist Frederick fish injure points
out that snot contains antiseptic
enzymes that kill or weaken bacteria
reintroducing those crippled
microorganisms may allow your immune
system to develop antibodies in relative
safety
that is good to knows but is eating your
own snot cannibalism self-cannibalism
just like a cow or chicken or fish or
fruit or vegetable you are made out of a
lot of edible things the meat on an
average human body contains 77,000
dietary calories worth of nutritional
energy YUM if you decide to become a
cannibal just don't show up late for
dinner where you'll get the cold
shoulder
[Music]
[Applause]
jokes aside cannibalism is a major taboo
it's off-putting at a visceral level
humans have dignity they are more than
just skin bags full of organs they're
more than just something to put on a
plate but human meat has been put on
plates and in bellies there are reports
of cannibalism occurring in times of
famine as a last resort and because of
curiosity and art in the late 1980s
artist Rick Gibson publicly ate human
tonsils and other donated human parts in
London and Canada in 2006 artist Marco
every city cooked and canned meatballs
prepared with his own body fat removed
by a liposuction in 2011 Dutch TV
presenters Dennis storm and Valerio xeno
cooked and ate pieces of each other on a
TV show whose title meant guinea pigs
because both of them lived and both
consented to the act they didn't do
anything illegal one year later a
Japanese man posted this tweet five
diners took up his offer and on April 13
2012 they were served a $250 per plate
meal consisting of his genitals a darker
story occurred in 2001 when Armin my vez
ate and killed a volunteer he found on
the now-defunct
cannibal cafe although his meal
ostensibly consented to the menu my this
was convicted of murder and now serving
a life sentence in prison has become a
devout vegetarian disgust aside one
question remains
if you were to use your taste buds
to taste your bud what would it taste
like to be clear taste is a sensation
caused by something in your mouth
chemically reacting with receptors in
your taste buds flavor is the even more
complex experience of taste
combined with smell and information from
the trigeminal nerve about things like
temperature texture pain and pungency as
far as the cooked but otherwise
unadulterated spice --less sauceless
flavor of human meat the late William
Seabrook provided in my opinion the best
description while in West Africa
Seabrook interviewed members of the Gear
tribe people who had eaten human flesh
and found their descriptions
unsatisfactory so when he returned to
Paris he struck a sneaky deal with an
intern at the Sorbonne and obtained a
chunk of human meat from an otherwise
healthy body recently involved in an
accident he carefully prepared the meat
and wrote that quote it was like good
fully developed veal not young but not
yet beef it was mild good meat with no
other sharply defined or highly
characteristic tastes such as for
instance goat high game and pork the
steak was slightly tougher than prime
veal a little stringy but not too tough
or stringy to be agreeably edible the
roast from which I cut and ate a central
slice was tender and in color texture
smell as well as taste strengthened my
certainty that of all the meats we
habitually know veal is the one meat to
which this meat is accurately comparable
Seabrook never gave us any recipes or
complimentary flavor recommendations but
that brings us to this video's titles
second meaning what does human taste
like what does the human palate prefer
interestingly of all the possible
combinations of identified flavors we
consume human cuisine only features a
relatively small number
of recipes a couple years ago scientific
reports published a great paper on the
chemistry and networks behind food
pairing researchers took 381 ingredients
used in 5 global cuisines and 1021
molecular compounds known to contribute
to their flavors and created a flavor
network the size of the bubble
represents the ingredients prevalence in
cooking the thickness of the lines
connecting ingredients reflects the
number of flavor inducing molecules they
significantly share the researchers
flavor Network backbone spans 14
different food categories and is quite
interesting by comparing this network to
tens of thousands of recipes they found
that North American and Western European
dishes tend to combine ingredients that
share flavor compounds while East Asian
cuisine avoids them but that trend was
caused by a few outliers in each cuisine
that if ignored caused the difference in
amount of sharing to lessen those few
ingredients tend to be the most
authentic they tend to be the most
responsible for the taste palate of a
regional cuisine and contribute to this
illuminating visualization but some
flavours don't go together in any
cuisine for instance orange juice and
toothpaste
why does orange juice taste so
disgusting right after brushing well
most toothpastes contain sodium lauryl
sulfate a chemical that helps the paste
get sudsy and frothy during use that
action helps pull brushed off debris
away from your teeth but sodium lauryl
sulfate also suppresses sweet receptors
in your mouth and destroys phospholipids
that inhibit your bitter receptors
making sweet orange juice taste not so
sweet and grossly bitter for up to an
hour after brushing
what interests me the most about flavor
is the fact that the things that cause
it eventually become you you are what
you eat
scientifically your body is always
losing dead cells but the elements and
molecules you ingest are processed by
your body into new body here's a fun way
to think about it under the direction of
DNA a cat is made out of air water and
cat food that's it cats have less varied
diets than humans we can taste sweetness
but cats lack the gene required to do so
however they can taste ATP a molecule
that moves around chemical energy for
cells to use in the body which may be
assigned to them that they're tasty meat
the point is sights and sounds and
textures and shapes and smells are the
names we give to things that eventually
become our memories but flavour is the
name we give to the experience of things
that eventually become our bodies
contemplating the flavor of human meat
is gross but think of it this way you
are currently tasting human you are
tasting human right now your tongue and
tastebuds are in contact with your mouth
almost constantly now granted it's more
of a passive thing your mouth just
happens to contain your tongue you're
not actually lead yourself
but you kind of are your body is
constantly swallowing your own mucus and
digesting pieces of your body like dead
cells from your tongue and cheek but
that's nothing compared to the
self-cannibalism of the sea squirt the
sea squirt lives a sort of self
cannibalistic flowers for algernon
lights when born it resembles a tadpole
and has a notochord putting it in the
same phylum as humans it swims around
until it finds a nice place to adhere a
rock a plant once stuck it begins
retrogressive metamorphosis literally
digesting its own nervous system eating
the closest thing it ever had to a brain
and lives the rest of its life in a
sense I'll unlock imodium clump it is a
bit of a downgrade but they are prime
evidence that the evolution of the brain
was spawned by the need to move as soon
as these guys don't need to move around
they eat their brains that is way more
extreme than the self cannibalism you
participate in every day by swallowing
but don't feel bad about every three
months or so you swallow and digest your
own bodyweight worth of you that means
that every day you are a little more
than 1% of the mythical or robber as'
the snake eating its own tail you are
what you eat but you were also a thing
that you eat and as always thanks for
watching
[Music]